Musik Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO mit Florentin Will und Stefan Thibidi-Titzler, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Herzlich willkommen, natürlich der dritte bei uns am Tisch, wie immer Max Acht, der achte Max mittlerweile. Unser Podcast ist mittlerweile acht Max lang. Wir haben schon acht Intros von Max bekommen und das ist Max Acht. Und du benennst die Files quasi nach Häufigkeit auftauchendes Namens Max Acht, Stefan Drei, Philipp 19 sind wir glaube ich mittlerweile. Philipp 29. Vielen, vielen Dank an Max Acht, ich würde sagen, unter den Top 5 der Max definitiv mit dabei. Vielen, vielen Dank für dieses fantastische Intro. Und natürlich auch danke, dass du heute extra hier rausgefahren bist, in dieses Studio. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Ja, nervt, nervt immer mehr. Jede Woche habe ich weniger Lust. Das kommunizierst du auch recht deutlich durch deine Körpersprache, wenn du hier durch die Türe gehst und diese sehr leichte Türe immer aufdrückst, als wäre sie hundert Kilo schwer. Und zuknalle, als ginge sie nicht zu. Und ja, merke ich schon wieder, ah ok, wird wieder eine anstrengende Frau. Ich dachte ja auch nie, hallo, ich setze mich einfach hier hin, dick eingepackt, Sonnenbrille auf, sodass du mich nicht erkennst, aus Angst, dass du mich erkennen könntest, dass man früh Smalltalk betrifft. Und dann kurz vor der Ausnahme nimmt ich die Sonnenbrille ab und sagt, ach hey, so und dann, dass man gar nicht mehr reden muss über privaten Scheiss oder sowas. Das Einzige, worüber sich Stefan noch beschwert, sind die Paparazzi vom Studio, das ist das Einzige, wo er hier und da noch mal Wortfetzen verliert, aber das ist auch mehr so ein Gegrummel eigentlich. Das ist mehr so ein werke Gegrummel einfach, weil das stört mich, aber ich habe mich damit arrangiert. Aber du achtest immer darauf, dass deine Socken nicht unter die Hose rutschen, also dass sie nicht unter die Hosenbeine rutschen. Wie? Das ist mir aufgefallen, dass das bei dir noch nie der Fall war. Hast du da irgendwie, hast du so einen Ring um den Hals, der dann so über den ganzen Körper hinweg die Socken auffällt? Genau, ich habe und zwar so kleine, kennt man ja von Hosenträgern, so Klemme, die man an die Hosen macht. Das habe ich von, also mein ganzer Körper besteht aus so einem, unter meiner Kleidung, unter so einem sehr filigranen Haltesystem. Und man muss sich das vorstellen, wenn ich meine Hose aussehen würde, da werden sehr viele, also die Socken, die Schuhe, alles wird separat gehalten von Schnür. Und alle spannen so gegeneinander und halten so einen konstanten Druck aus. Normalerweise wäre ich noch grösser, drei Meter acht ungefähr. Aber dadurch, dass so viel Spannung auf diesen ganzen Körperteilen liegt und so,
man kann aber auch nichts, also auch jedes einzelne Haar wird einzeln befestigt
und läuft hinten so einer kleinen Minischnur, die man aber nicht sieht, am Rücken herunter.
Ich finde das gut. Können wir das den Titzler machen denn, wenn man so seine Socken so hochzieht,
unter der Hose?
Schon besetzt, Titzler machen ist ein doppeltes Rad schlagen.
Ach scheinbar, stimmt.
Jetzt habe ich ganz vergessen, die Olympiade 98, du warst ja da, warst ja am Start, also dabei am Anfang. Ich war am Start, also das kann man, genau so kann man das sagen, ich war am Start. Du hast versucht, einen neuen Trick zu etablieren, den Titzler, du hast ihn angesetzt. Genau. Und dabei würde ich sagen, belassen wir das. Dabei belassen wir das Thema. Auch einfach. Es ist eine sehr kurze Doku über den Sportler Stefan Tietze und sagt, er war anwesend, er hat teilgenommen. Von mir kommt der Satz, dabei sein ist alles auch. Und 80 Minuten Outro, ja, das geht auch, klickt sich. Von mir kommt der Satz, dabei sein ist alles, und ich glaube auch, das ist richtig, dass der Satz von einem kommt, der jemanden bekommt, der nicht gewonnen hat. Ja, natürlich, klar. Wohingegen die Gewinner schreiben die Geschichte, kommt
bestimmt von einem Gewinner. Ja.
Wohingegen das legendäre Zitat von
Mohammed Ali, Gewinnen ist alles.
Aber was natürlich aus seiner Perspektive
nachvollziehbar ist, dass er das sagen will.
Es ist immer eine Frage der Perspektive.
Absolut. Ich habe gerade vor der Aufnahme
die lustigste Instagram-Werbung
der Welt bekommen.
Und ich nehme es auch ein bisschen als Affront wahr.
Und zwar, vielmehr möchte ich jetzt
nicht sagen, weil das wäre Werbung,
Aber ... die lustigste Instagram-Werbung der Welt bekommen. Und ich nehme es auch ein bisschen als Affront wahr. Und zwar, vielmehr möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil das wäre Werbung, aber es ist ein Dienst, da kann man was bestellen. Und zwar, ich lese mal die Biografie vor, Our mission is to help you express yourself via your signature. Also, sie wollen mir eine bessere Signatur machen. Eine Unterschrift. Und ich dachte erst, weil das war in etwa das Foto, was ich bekommen habe als Werbung angezeigt, ich dachte, das sind Visitenkarten mit so einer coolen Unterschrift drauf. Aber nein, es stellt sich raus, es ist einfach nur, sie wollen dir eine coolere Unterschrift machen und dann kann man die übernehmen. Also du bezahlst wahrscheinlich so einen Obolus von 10 Dollar oder sowas und hast dann eine neue Unterschrift und dann kannst du die übernehmen. Aber ich finde es schon nervig, ehrlich gesagt, also erstmal die Frage, kann man einfach seine Unterschrift wechseln? Zweitens, das ist so wahnsinnig aufwendig, wenn der DHL-Bote mir so ein Ding dahinhält, kann ich ja nicht erstmal meinen Kalligrafieset rausholen und mich selbst verwirklichen in dem Ding. Vor allem, das riecht doch einfach wie ein Scam, oder? Weil die kennen ja dann deine Unterschrift. Aha. Wenn die dir die Unterschrift designen. Ich war gut, das zu machen. Das ist nämlich dann, deswegen bin ich froh, dass ich dich im Leben habe. Ja. Weil du sagst, warum sollst du jetzt deine Kreditkartennummer geben? Natürlich, weil die haben ja dann deine Kreditkartennummer, die haben deine Adresse, die haben deine Telefonnummer und die haben deine Unterschrift. Und diese CVV-Code, der hinten noch der Kreditel ist. Genau, die haben alles, was sie brauchen, um dein Leben komplett zu übernehmen. Stimmt, die haben auch gesagt, sie können mir meine Sozialversicherungsnummer schöner schreiben. Wo ich dachte, deswegen habe ich denen die auch schon geschickt. Deswegen weiß ich nicht genau. Wir können ihre Sozialversicherungsnummer zu 19 Dreien machen. Das ist unser Dienst. Das ist ja leicht zu merken. In binär. Wollen Sie Ihre Sozialversicherungsnummer in binär angezeigt bekommen? Dann schicken Sie uns einfach Ihre Sozialversicherungsnummer und zehn Dollar. Genial. Ja, super, aber ich finde in der modernen Zeit die Unterschrift eh so ein bisschen merkwürdig. Ich meine natürlich, klar, als ich mit 16 meinen Ausweis bekommen habe, habe ich die Unterschrift geübt den ganzen Tag, bevor ich zum Amt gegangen bin, weil ich natürlich auch überlegt habe,
klar, wie wird das mal später sein am roten Teppich, so, dann brauchst du eine coole Unterschrift. Ja, und deswegen nehme ich auch als Affront wahr, dass die jetzt offensichtlich meine Unterschrift für schlecht halten und mir jetzt meinen, sie brauchen Hilfe bei ihr. Was ist das für ein Werbung-Targeting? Was sagen die, okay, ihr seid eine Firma für Unterschriften und was wollt ihr, an welche Leute richtet ihr euch? Ja, ähm, Leute mit einer sauklau. Mit einer sauhässlichen Unterschrift, die quasi auf diesem Schreibschriftniveau stehen geblieben sind. Da, ich bereue es immer noch. Meine Unterschrift fängt mit dem kleinen Schreibschrift F an, was vielleicht einer der entstelltesten Schreibschriftbuchstaben ist, die es überhaupt gibt. Der lange hochgezogene Kringel nach unten. Der lange Strich nach unten. Und dann nochmal der Strich von links nach rechts, also weit weg von, also vielleicht das kleine S, glaube ich, ist noch das allerschlimmste Schreibschriftzeichen überhaupt, aber das kleine F und heute, ich schäme mich jedes Mal dafür, jedes Mal schäme ich mich dafür, wenn ich damit unterschreiben muss. Aber das heisst, du hast lange geübt deine Unterschrift, was ja auch schon so Narzissmus Anflug bedeutet. Vor allem Will ist ja einfach nur zickzack. Will ist einfach nur ein zickzack. Kleines f und dann blablabla. Genau, aber das ist dabei rausgekommen. Nach dem Üben hast du dich entschieden, ich plus kleine f. Bei mir ist es auch so, ich habe viel geübt, aber am Ende, wenn es darauf ankommt, werde ich zu nervös und ich feile wieder in alte Muster zurück. Weißt du, was ich meine? Man fällt wieder in alte Geflogenheiten zurück. Es ist schwer, ab welchem Punkt man in seinem Leben sagt, nein, jetzt brauche ich eine neue Unterschrift, jetzt muss es losgehen. Ich glaube, spätestens wenn man so einen Hauskauf unterzeichnet, da kann man nicht mehr seinen Kringel, Krösel dahinschreiben. Da muss man sagen, nein, jetzt braucht man so einen T und Strich. Ich habe jetzt neulich einen wichtigen Vertrag unterzeichnet, auch Unterschrift geübt, erst gross, ne? Und dann kam ein digitales Formular, was man digital unterschreiben konnte.
Ja. Und dann klickt man da drauf auf Unterschrift setzen und dann gibt man seinen Namen ein und es wird so getan. Und ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mal hattest, aber das ist das Weirdeste der Welt, dann wird ja einfach eine Unterschrift generiert. Ja, genau.
Und zwar ist die halt, was einfach so eine Handwritten Typo ist, einfach, die aber sehr klar ist und offensichtlich nicht von jemandem geschrieben. Und jetzt habe ich mich gefragt, jetzt haben wir aber Unterschriften, der komplett einen Wert verloren. Es ist super alt. Niemand checkt, was das überhaupt noch soll. Weil wenn das jemand vorhält, jetzt haben sie doch unterschrieben, sag ich, äh, nein. Also man kann, kommt ja super leicht raus. Das ist doch Ihr Name. Ja, richtig. Na also. Ja, aber den kann ja jeder mit dieser Font untersetzen. Hier, wie heißen Sie, wie heißen Sie? Ronald Rügelmann. So, Ronald Rügelmann, gebe ich mal hier ein. So, rappababam, hier schön, areale Handwritten. Das will ich jetzt mal sehen. So, und jetzt hier, ist auch eine Handwritten-Strecht von Ihrem Namen. Scheiße. So, jetzt haben Sie das Haus gekauft. Scheiße. Jetzt haben Sie es gekauft, die Bruchbude. Ja, es ist schwierig. Darf man denn jetzt mal so ganz privat nachfragen, was das für ein wichtiger Vertrag war? Nee, es war für uns. Es war für, es war, wie... Die Scheidung endlich durch, oder was? Ich habe die Scheidung unterschrieben. Wir müssen bald bei dir ankommen. Okay. Hast du ein Boot gekauft? Ja, okay.
Alles klar. Das habe ich mir schon fast gedacht.
Du hast wieder den Segelhut auf,
du hast wieder dieses Tuch
um den Hals, man kennt es.
Man kennt diesen, ich habe mir gerade was
grosses gekauft Blick. Frag mich
doch bitte danach. Frag mich jetzt bitte, was ich
gekauft habe. So wenn du so ein neues Tattoo hast und
irgendwie so dein halber Körper knallrot ist mit
dieser Plastikfolie, aber
du willst erst mal, dass Leute nachfragen.
Weißt du was, das wäre
Das ist ein, das wir jetzt noch nicht mehr sehen. So, wenn du so ein neues Tattoo hast und dein halber Körper knallrot ist mit dieser Plastikfolie, aber du willst erst mal, dass Leute nachfragen.
Weißt du was, das wäre so out of character, wenn du ein Tattoo hättest. Und ich fände das so lustig und cool. Wäre das nicht mal was, einfach mal so einen Akzent setzen, der erst mal Leute verwirrt. Also weil du jetzt bei den Rocket Beans Büros laufen würdest und jetzt plötzlich so ein Anker auf der Schulter und so einen Tanktop tragen, würden doch alle kurz sagen, also du würdest so Double Takes auf dich ziehen. Ich glaube, ich würde mir ein Gesicht von dir tätowieren lassen und dann, wenn wir darüber reden, würde ich sagen, ich denke, du hättest das gewollt.
Und dann denken alle, ich bin gestorben.
Dann denken die Leute, du bist gestorben und schwer krank, aber nein. Und ich versuche eigentlich nur, dir damit ein sehr schlechtes Gewissen zu machen. Sehr aufwendiger Gag. Oder so dein Kopf mit einem Datum drüber. So 2024. Und du weißt nicht, was passiert an dem Tag. So was in der Richtung. Finde ich eigentlich auch eine schlechte Idee. 23.05.2024 und dann mein Gesicht. Und dann nehmen wir so ein Kreuz. Alle fragen sich, was passiert an dem Tag. Sehr langwieriges Setup für den Gag. Er hätte es so gewollt, ehrlich gesagt. Das hättest du ja auch, kannst du ja sonst auch mal sagen, einfach. Das hätte Stefan so gewollt. Oder einfach so deine, oder deine Unterschrift, deine neue Unterschrift auf meinem Arm. So, als würde ich dir gehören. Oder unter die Ferse. Ja. Unter die Ferse schreibe ich Stefan, wie bei Toy Story, als würde ich dir gehören. Stefan? Ja. Ich finde es gut, ich habe überlegt, da mal einfach zu sagen, ja, ich mache mal diese neue Unterschrift. Warum nicht? Mein Experiment war... Hol mal ein Angebot ein, du kannst ja immer ein Angebot reinholen und dann sagen, gefällt dir die Unterschrift ja oder nein, aber kannst du da auch sagen, ich würde gerne eine Unterschrift haben wie ein Präsident. Also wirklich so eine all in rule the weather. Einfach so wirklich auch so lange Namen. So einfach Franklin D. Rosenhower. Franklin D. rule the weather. Als Präsident ruht man ja das Weather. Im Grunde schon. Ja, zu einem gewissen Teil schon. Ich meine, wenn man nämlich bei Präsidenten auf die Wikipedia-Artikel geht, kann man ja die Unterschrift sehen. Kann man damit, kann ich nicht die mal unter unseren neuen Vertrag von unseren Werbehelfern. Ja, weiß ich gar nicht. Donald Trump, da an der Unterschrift finde ich, sieht man schon, dass er kein guter Präsident sein kann. Ja. Ja, ne, weil die sind normalerweise... Smoke stumpf. Es ist nicht leicht zu lesen, was da steht, aber es stimmt schon. Ich finde das sehr lustig, theoretisch zu überlegen, das mal zu reverse-engineeren. Das wäre mal ein Quizformat. Wie du kannst, kommt rein. Wir sehen, wo Unterschriften ... Leerer Raum. Komplett leerer Raum, eine Kamera. Aber niemand dahinter, die ist fix. Er kommt rein und man sieht dann, hält er hoch auf Pappen, Unterschriften von Prominenten und wir als Zuschauer müssen raten, oder Prominente müssen raten, von wem die ist. Das ist auch lustig. Dann steht da Barbara Schöneberger und man muss ja raten, von wem die Unterschrift ist. Ja, genau. Das ist so ein … Ne, ist furchtbar das Format, aber hier bei dieser Unterschrift, bei Donald Trump zum
Beispiel, da würdest du es furchtbar, das Format, aber hier bei dieser Unterschrift,
bei Donald Trump zum Beispiel, da würdest du es nicht sofort sagen.
Ne, du würdest es überhaupt nicht merken.
Jonas Stumpf.
Jonas Stumpf, der ist ja so, stimmt nicht Jonas Stumpf, weil du kannst ja auch einfach
die Unterschrift unter deine Verträge setzen, so gerade bei digitalen Signaturen,
und am Ende kannst du sagen, ja sie haben das Haus aber gekauft, nö, das habe ich nicht gekauft.
Das ist Jonas Stumpf. Jonas Stumpf hat das gekauft. Wenden Sie sich an den. Ich habe da überhaupt nichts zu tun. Aber erst mal ganz, ganz naiv nachgefragt. Hast du schon jemals was gelesen, was du unterschrieben hast? Nein. Ich habe mal beruflich auf die Frage zu antworten einen sehr, sehr wichtigen Vertrag, den ich bekommen habe, einfach nicht gelesen und unterschrieben und zurückgeschickt, woraufhin mich ein Arbeitskollege, der den gleichen Vertrag bekommen hat, angerufen hat und gesagt hat, dann machst du eigentlich einen neuen Vertrag gelesen und ich schon so, meine erste Rechtsgrund war, oh shit, weil ich habe schon zurückgeschickt. Und dann hat er nämlich mit einer Kollegin, die auch den Vertrag gelesen hat, gesagt, das war eine Vertragsveränderung und dann habe ich gesagt, ja gut, hätte man zumindest mal vergleichen können, weil mir wurde gesagt, das ist einfach der wie der Alte.
Aber der Alte war eine Seite lang und der Neue war 13 Seiten lang. Und selbst das hat bei mir keine Redflex.
Das ist nur ein bisschen blumiger formuliert, Stefan, mach dir keine Sorgen.
Ich dachte einfach ein bisschen netter ausformuliert die Sachen und so auch allgemeinverständlicher gemacht und so.
Da wird sich schon jemand was dabei gedacht haben. Wenn man bei jemandem einen Vertrag hinlegt und sagt, das ist basically das ist der gleiche Vertrag, den du vorher unterschrieben hast, gar keine Reaktion, schreibt sofort Donald Trump runter. Natürlich. Und ja, und dann kam raus, dass sehr viele Sachen drin sind und ich bin jetzt, naja, ich hänge jetzt in, warum, wenn ich mich frage, warum nicht mehr so viel von mir zu hören ist, Ich kann eben auch nicht mehr entscheiden, was ich mache.
Also Leute haben mich in der Hand. Ich glaube, das Mindestmaß, was ich mache, ist ein ...
Okay, ja, alles klar, unterschreiben.
Also dieses einfach Blättern und grobes Gucken, gibt es Bilder, gibt es Statistiken, aber ansonsten einfach nur dieses,
aha, ja, okay, das sieht gut aus, Text, Buchstaben, Helvetica, ja, das ist alles in Ordnung, wunderbar, genau, alles klar. Das muss schon sein. Ganz ohne Irgendeine Interaktion darfst du es schon auch nicht unterschreiben. Es ist die Frage, dieser Vertrag wurde nämlich unterschrieben von mir daheim, privat, er kam postalisch zu mir.
Ja gut, da ist man natürlich freier.
Da ist man frei, mach was man will.
Wenn mir jemand zuschiebt und der Vertragsverfasser, dann würde ich auch wahrscheinlich erstmal so tun.
Aber da die Frage, wie lange muss ich lesen, bis es gesellschaftlich common sense ist, dass man einfach jetzt unterschreiben kann.
Da muss man schon, so eine Minute muss man schon blättern. Ich meine, Text ist ja auch nicht wirklich die individuellste Medium eigentlich. Weil gerade im digitalen Zeitalter kann man zum Beispiel sagen, du unterschreibst einen Vertrag mit deiner Stimme. Du sagst, ich meine, bei der Hochzeit, von Anfang an haben die gesagt, lass uns die Unterschrift machen, aber zentral ist, dass ich will, am Altar, das zählt, weil die Stimme ist individuell. Ja, vor Gott. Ich weiss es nicht mehr, gesört, geschört. Hat mich mal gestört. Ich habe das mal gesehen, dass es man theoretisch gerade viel generieren kann, Computer generieren kann. Stimmen nicht. Bei Stimmen ist man nach wie vor auf SchauspielerInnen angewiesen. Tarkan hat diese Woche ganz fantastisch auf Instagram in der Story gepostet, über den sehr ambitionierten Versuch, wie ich finde, die Stimme eines Pharaos zu rekonstruieren. Und dafür wurde diese Mumie dann in den Kernspintomographen geschoben und man hat das alles analysiert und Stimmbänder und so versucht zu rekonstruieren. Und dann hat man dann das 3D gedruckt, wie dann seine Stimmbänder und seine Kehle und all das aussah, um dann eben einen Ton daraus zu generieren, um einfach mal einen Einblick zu bekommen, wie klang das eigentlich damals in Ägypten, in der Pharao-Zeit. Aber erst die Dinosaurier und jetzt die Ägypter machen sie auch noch uncool.
Die arbeiten sich gerade, diese blöden Wissenschaftler arbeiten sich gerade an den Phasen meiner Kindheit ab.
Ich hatte eine Ägyptenphase, was kommt als nächstes?
Dass sie mir die Dinos weggenommen, und wenn die jetzt, willst du kurz gucken?
Weil wenn die mir jetzt noch die geilen, coolen, charismatischen Pharaonen wegnehmen.
Ich zeig dir hier mal ganz kurz den Ausschnitt.
Ja, jetzt ist ja meine Anschlussfrage.
Ja, und jetzt?
Recreating his mouth and vocal chords with a 3D printer.
It allowed them to produce a single sound.
Aber ganz ehrlich, alles dieser Kopfschmuck und diese Augenbrauen und diese vielen Sklaven und so, ehrlich gesagt, man stellt sich doch die genauso vor. Nää. Nää. Entschuldigung, die Sklaven verlangen eine Gewerkschaft und besseres Arbeitsrecht. Nää. Okay, dann nicht. Lassen wir. Jahrhundertelange Regentschaft, einfach basierend auf Anwälte. Näää. Aber mit so einer abfälligen Handbewegung und so. Aber ohne Scheiss, warum wollt ihr das denn heraus ... Erst mal, gut, wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie im fliessenden Ägyptisch, inoglyphen-Sprache so einen Text hätte vorsagen können.
Ja.
Meine Damen und Herren, wir eröffnen heute die Pyramide.
So, das wäre halt geil.
Das ist eine Ägypten-Imitation.
Wir eröffnen heute die Pyramide hier in Kairo.
Weee! Vielleicht war das damals die große Eröffnung der Pyramide. Wieder hier in Kairo.
Vielleicht war das damals die große Eröffnung der Pyramide.
Ja, aber es haben sich halt einlaut rausgefunden.
Und ehrlich gesagt, frage ich mich, was es jetzt bringt. Ah, diese Wissenschaftler, wie können die denn tagelang, wochenlang, monatelang an diesem Projekt arbeiten und mit dem Ergebnis zufrieden sein?
Glaubst du, hat jemand immer gelacht?
Macht der lieber Autotune? Das ist nämlich das Ding. Hat einer von denen mal gelacht, als er das gehört hat. Und wenn nicht, man muss lachen. Man muss fucking Stock im Arsch. Du stellst die richtigen Fragen. Nääääää. Naja, also so viel zum Thema Pharao. Ja, okay.
Irgendwie lame.
In unserer Antenne Ägypten, Entschuldigung.
Das war Antenne Ägypten. Das war Antenne Ägypten.
Ägyptische Musik war jetzt nicht so einfach für mich, nachzukonstruieren.
So ein Sandsturm?
Das ist mir nicht schlecht.
Nililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil, nil. Sag ich auch einfach gern. Und dann würde ich da, ich hätte mir auch so ein richtig schönes, großes Grabmal gebaut für die Nachwelt.
Ja, fängst du jetzt schon an, eine Statue zu bauen oder ein Grabmal oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung? Mir selbst? Oder zumindest mal festzulegen, wie eine Statue aussehen würde. Also dass du im Testament sagst, ich weiss, klar, ihr Podcaster, super erfolgreiche Netflix-Serie und so, bin es nicht super besonderes, aber falls ihr mit dem Gedanken spielt, eine Statue von mir zu bauen, nachher abnehmen. Sind hier 39.000 Vorschläge, mit denen ich leben könnte. Sind hier mögliche Outfits, die ich mal abfotografiert habe, die ich vielleicht da haben wollen würde. So was. Gute Frage. Hat man dann, also klar, früher Rüstungen, wurden die Leute mit Rüstungen, jetzt heutzutage im T-Shirt. Also Martin Luther King oder so wird wahrscheinlich im Anzug als Statue präsentiert. Ja, aber jetzt bin ich ja nicht durch meine Auftritte im Anzug bekannt. Ja, du bist halt einfach Real Bad Bitch T-Shirts bekannt. Ja, stehe ich dann mit so einem Watch Out, I'm in the Night Watch Shirt, Watch-Watch-Shirt, Watch-out-Ladies, I'm-in-the-Night-Watch, ist das dann ... In so einem Bauchbeutel und einfach so, wo die Leute in 200 Jahren sich fragen würden, was?
Meine Frage ist, glaube ich, konkret, werde ich dann mit so einem schlecht sitzenden T-Shirt, für die ich bekannt bin, abgebildet.
Wahrscheinlich.
Und so einem Hoodie, der zu kurz ist.
Was ist die neueste Statue? Welche Person ...
Stockernst gemeinte Frage, welche Persönlichkeit aus den letzten 30 Jahren verdient deiner Meinung nach eine Statue? Verdient? Ja. Aber was ist das für Statue? Wo steht die in der Innenstadt rum? Ja, ein bisschen außerhalb, in so einem Park. In so einem Park. Schlingensief. Okay. So, ich zeige dir nämlich mal, es gibt nämlich eine moderne Statue. Die sind dann eher so abstrakt, ne? Die haben dann irgendwie so ganz langgezogene Köpfe. Nee, überhaupt nicht abstrakt. Fünfköpfe und sowas in der Richtung. Von Cristiano Ronaldo. Und das war doch auch ein Riesending. Ja, das war doch ein Prank. Nein. Aber die ist jetzt neu gemacht worden. Aber da gab es eine Büste. Und er hat die selber dann so abgemacht und das war das Gesicht von Cristiano Ronaldo. Das wird vielleicht nachreichen. Ja, aber guck mal, das ist das Problem, dass es in unserer Gesellschaft kaum noch Statuen gibt. Wir haben keine richtig guten Bildhauer mehr. Das prangere ich jetzt wirklich schon seit Jahren an, dass damals im antiken Griechenland, antiken Rom, da gab es wirklich gute Bildhauer, die haben das tagtäglich gemacht, die hatten richtig Laufkundschaft.
Und heutzutage, wenn du sagst, Statue, sagt einer, ja, keine Ahnung, ich hab mal irgendwie viel mit Knete gemacht als Kind.
Ja, du machst den Job, okay, du hast den Job, das neunzehn Jobs.
Und dann ärgert man sich, dass am Ende so ein verkorkster Ronaldo rauskommt.
Und dann gibt's eine andere, das zieht sich irgendwie durch Cristiano Ronaldos Leben durch, nämlich eine andere Figur, wo er erstens nicht so aussieht wie er aussieht im Gesicht und zweitens irgendwie man guckt woanders hin. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber er hat eine ganz grosse Ausbeulung in der Schrittgegend, merkwürdig auch tausend, also wenn das das Outfit von Fussballern wäre. Vor allem jeder weiss, dass ja bei Statuen man immer an einer Stelle reibt, um Glück zu haben. Ich glaube, als Statuenbauer legt man sowas natürlich auch schon an und sagt dankend, okay, wo ist die Stelle? Das ist so merkwürdig. Das ist super merkwürdig. Aber sie wurde auch jetzt in ein Museum verlegt. Ich kann mir vorstellen, aus guten Gründen. Zu viele Leute haben, glaube ich, die Statue angefasst, ungebührlich angefasst. Ja, aber du kannst ja jetzt ein Outfit festlegen. Du kannst ja jetzt sagen, du willst den Hoodie, du willst die Jeans, du willst den Ed Hardy-Gürtel, du willst irgendwie einen Cape, du willst deinen Kapitänshut, den du seit Monaten nicht ausziehst. Das sind so die Dinge, die dir wichtig sind. Ich will nur den Hut. Und der Rest wäre so David-mäßig, würde ich dann nackt sein. Okay, dann bräuchten wir aber auch da Bilder. Nee, nee, nee. Naja, wir müssen ja schon real... Ja, ihr kriegt Mutbilder von mir. Mutbilder? Mut, M-O-O-D-Bilder, die ihr so dann, wie ich mir das, wie ihr euch das so vorstellen könnt. Naja, aber das muss ja schon ihr Körper sein, damit das echt ist. Ja, nee, muss ja nicht, muss ja nicht. Naja, eigentlich schon, das ist ja... Nääääää. Ah, okay, sie haben recht. Gut, sie sind ja... Ich glaube, so kommt man weit. Ich glaube, so kommt man weit. Und viele Chefs, denen man so begegnet, haben nämlich diese Attitude. Weißt du, was ich meine? Ja. Siehste? Ja. Ich glaube, du kommst so weit, weil niemand traut sich ja auch, was dagegen zu sagen. Ja. Nee, das ist die bessere Absage, wenn du sagst, und kommst du heute Abend noch dann so, ja, muss ich mal schauen. Und du sagst, nein, das ist nein. Aber durch dieses, ja, ja, da sagt man einfach schon, ja, nein, nein, das ist einfach nicht dabei.
Aber verstehe ich jetzt nicht genau. Also die haben halt diesen Kieferknochen nachgebaut, bla bla bla bla. Ja, und dann einfach Luft durchgepustet.
So funktioniert ja auch menschliche Sprache. Der Mensch ist ja eigentlich nur die grosse Flöte.
Ja, wir sind eine grosse Flöte. Im Grunde kommt die Luft von unten, wo auch immer her. Wir sind Mensch ist ja eigentlich nur eine grosse Flöte. Ja, wir sind eine grosse Flöte.
Im Grunde kommt die Luft von unten, wo auch immer her.
Wir sind eine wandelnde, winkende Flöte.
Im Grunde kann man es so zusammenfassen.
Und dann kommt hier aus den Ballons im Körper Wut, wie so ein Dudelsack da rausgeschossen und dann klingt es so.
Genau.
Da brauchst du halt auch eine Zunge, ne?
Wenn jetzt halt mal nur Ton ohne Zunge machst, dann ist halt auch wirklich nicht viel, ne? Äh, äh, äh. Aber die haben ja auch neulich mal versucht, Leute nachzubauen anhand von Bildern, also Porträts, die es gab und Knochen. Und Leute sahen schon einfach weird aus damals. Man hat sich schon verändert, ich glaube, was heißt weird, also ungewohnt.
Ja und halt wenn irgendwie dann so Pontius Pilatus genau so aussieht wie Ralf Schmitz, ist halt schon komisch, so das wirft halt schon Fragen auf, wo du denkst, also wirklich halt genau aus dem Gesicht geschnitten. Ja, wo man auch sagt, hat mal jemand die Geburtsurkunde von Ralf Schmitz gesehen? Ja, oder mal seine Eckenzähne genau angeguckt.
Ja, also vielleicht, also jetzt nur mal so pro forma, dass man da einfach mal den Zahnarzt konsultiert. Ich sage gern pro forma und ich sage gern per se. Oh ja, per se ist gut. Per se ist ein Wort, es lässt dich cleverer klingen als du bist. Da kann man per se nichts dagegen sagen, aber auch pro forma würde ich schon noch mal einige Bedenken anmelden. Genau, kann man es anmelden, aber ich glaube, wie man sagt, per se kann man per se erstmal überall einbringen. Und man muss auch nicht so viele Gedanken machen, wo in dem Satz. Es macht schon Sinn. Also per se, niemand würde sagen, das hast du aber falsch benutzt. Das ist eines dieser, ich sag mal, fremdartigen Satzteile, die man einfach so reinwerfen kann. Schmeißt die einfach mal rein, streut die einfach rein, das ist wie Rosinen, packt die überall mit rein, fuck it, es wird schon funktionieren einigermassen, macht euch da keine Sorgen, aber kann man eigentlich auch mit so einem Vampirgebiss zum Zahnarzt gehen, so als Gag? Klar, macht das mal. Und dann einfach so, ja, ich hab hier an der Seite irgendwie Schmerzen und dann musst du erstmal immer das Vampirgebiss raustun. Macht mal mehr so Alterspranks und wir haben alle Handys dabei, ihr filmt das mal bitte jetzt, wie ihr mit einem Vampirgebiss da reingeht zum Arzt.
Ja, geht mal zum Friseur und versteckt davor wirklich Cornflakes in den Haaren.
Und was ich auch mal gerne sehen will.
Und dass ihr einfach denkt, was geht hier vor sich.
Einfach mal ein paar Pranks raushauen. Einfach mal ein paar Pranks raushauen. Und stellt mal so eine Toblerone, so wie so ein Kundendifferenzierungsmodul, dahin. Und guckt mal, ob die da aufhören zu scannen und da reinschieben, oder ob die es noch mitscannen. Oder ob die sagen, gehört das dann auch noch zu ihnen? Oder legt einfach mal alle Kundendifferenzierungsmodule auf einen Stapel aufs Band und versucht es zu kaufen. Macht mal weirden Scheiss jetzt! Verdammt nochmal! Ich stehe in der Kasse und jeder macht seinen gleichen Scheiss immer, jedes Mal. Ja, jedes Mal piep piep piep. Ja, warum da nicht mal so ein Beat rein, piep, piep, beat oder einfach mal so eine Tonleiter, so piep, piep, piep, piep, piep, piep, piep, piep, piep, sowas in der Richtung.
Sowas. Ich habe jetzt auf jeden Fall diese Selbstcheckouts für mich entdeckt, die Selbstkassierer. Problem funktioniert halt nie. Weil also, erst mal muss man ja quasi, wenn man etwas scant, hinlegen auf die Waage, auf das Abstellmodul. Das ist eine Waage, damit er erkennt, hast du auch alles abgepackt. Ich verstehe auch nicht warum. Warum muss man das wiegen danach? Was musst du wiegen? Alle Sachen werden, also, ich hatte immer ein Problem. Und dann dachte ich, ich habe es verstanden, aber wenn ich das laut ausspreche, hab ich es nicht verstanden. Dafür ist der Podcast da. Wenn du jetzt einen Korp hast zum Beispiel, stellst du den links neben dieses Ding, neben dieses Scanner-Dingen. So, und rechts hast du noch eine Ablage. Da stellst du deine leere Tasche, legst du da drauf. Da darfst du nicht ... Das hastst du nicht später machen, weil dann denkt es, du hast was draufgelegt, was du noch nicht gescannt hast. So legst du dann eine Tasche dahin. So, und dann kannst du zum Beispiel von links aus dem Korb etwas scannen und in die Tasche tun. Und erst wenn du es in der Tasche hast, darfst du weiter scannen. Das heißt, du musst, bist gezwungen, das erst alles abzulegen. Das ist ja wesentlich mehr Hightech, als ich das hier erlebt habe. Aber warum? Ich verstehe diesen Step halt nicht. Ja, wahrscheinlich damit du nicht klauen kannst. Aber du kannst ja auch einfach davor schon fünf Produkte rein. Du kannst ja davor alles in deinen Rucksack packen. Nee, ich kenne das nicht mit diesem Gewicht. Bist du dir sicher? Ja, genau. Wo hast du das so gefunden? Mein Problem war nämlich, ich hatte immer so eine Sporttasche dabei. Und da habe ich die Sporttasche da hingelegt. Da war aber noch ganz viel andere Kram drin. Das heißt, da waren schon so zehn Kilo rechts auf dieser Waage. Dann habe ich nämlich bei jedem einzelnen Produkt, was ich da reingelegt habe, hat die Maschine gesagt, sie haben viel zu viel draufgelegt. Was fällt ihnen ein? Sie beklauen doch gerade Rewe. Und dann kamen Leute zu mir, haben gesagt, was machen sie hier? Und ich habe gesagt, ja, ich habe das da hingestellt, aber da sind schon Sachen drin. Und dann musste ich das aufwenden, ich musste die wieder alles rückgängig machen, diesen Vorgang löschen und ich war gezwungen, meine Sportartstatt auf den Boden zu stellen. Wenn dir dann drei Leute helfen müssen, an der Selbstcheckout-Kasse zu zahlen. Ich kenne das anders, ich kenne das nur, dass man alles abhebt und dann zahlt man oder halt nicht und dann geht man. Okay. Also das mit diesem Gewichtssystem habe ich noch nie gehört. Ich weiss nicht warum das so ist. Ich bin entsetzt. Also das ist so, macht das irgendwie schwierig und unsexy. Ja. Weil an irgendeinem Punkt ist man auch einfach wieder bei einer Kasse. Also wenn dann Leute kommen und die helfen müssen, das zu scannen und so einen Scheiß und das freischalten und so, dann denkt man ja, dann wäre ich lieber zur Kasse gegangen. Die sind auch neuerdings immer leer. Also Leute wollen lieber ...
Das Ding ist, man hat ja als Kass... und so, dann denkt man ja, dann wäre ich lieber zur Kasse gegangen. Die sind auch neulichens immer leer.
Also Leute wollen lieber, das Ding ist, man hat ja als Kassiererin wahrscheinlich die Angst, dass einem Arbeitsplätze weggenommen werden, wenn gegenüber diese fiesen Automaten hingebaut werden. Jetzt kommt es dazu. Die auch so diese Totenkopfköpfe, Roboterköpfe haben, die ganze Zeit mit roten Augen anstecken. Die haben halt diese Mordor-Architektur. Ja, genau.
So, und dann gehen die alle dahin.
Und selbst wenn es da super voll ist ... Köpfe, Roboterköpfe haben. Genau. Die ganze Zeit mit roten Augen ansteigen. Die haben halt diese Mordor-Architektur. Ja, genau.
Und dann gehen die alle dahin und selbst wenn es da super voll ist
und die Kasse leer ist,
gehen Leute lieber an diese, ich zum
Beispiel, lieber an die Selbstcheckouts.
Ich will lieber warten
und nicht mit einem Menschen interagieren,
als eher den Laden verlassen. Absolut.
Aber ich weiß nicht, in welcher Cyberwelt
du da unterwegs bist, dass das so krass mit Wagen stattfindet. Das kenne ich überhaupt nicht. Das finde ich verrückt.
In der Schweiz gibt es mittlerweile Läden, wo man einfach reingehen kann und Dinge scannen kann und rausgehen kann wieder. Du gehst da rein mit dem QR-Code, den du hast, der ist in deinem Profil hinterlegt, gehst rein in den Laden, musst dann alles, was du kaufst, scannen.
Es sind überall Milliarden Kameras, starren dich an und du, natürlich klaust du dann nicht. Und dann, ne, scannst du alles ab und gehst wieder raus. Supergeil. Warum hast du das jetzt so betont, dass du nicht klaust? Nee, das würde man ja niemals machen. Nee, aber auch so durch die ganzen Kameras, die einen da angucken, würde man ja nicht mal auf die Idee kommen, Leute.
Was man da vielleicht auch bald kaufen kann, ist das Podcast-Ufo, die Duftkerze, die Begleitduftkerze für den Lieblingsfilm, den Lieblingspodcast, das Lieblingsbuch. Moviesense. Geschichtete, und das ist wichtig, geschichtete Kerzen. Viele Leute haben mir Bilder geschickt von Es gibt doch schon Kerzen zu Filmen, Zombiefilmen oder so, riecht er nach Verwesung, super, aber ich rede von Schichten. Jetzt hast du zu Recht angezweifelt mein gesamtes Geschäftsmodell in die Kritik genommen, in den Würgegriff der Kritik genommen und hast gesagt, na, funktioniert das denn überhaupt? Wenn die erste Schicht abgebrannt ist, die riecht nach Kirsche, dann brennt die Kerze weiter auf die zweite Schicht, die riecht nach Pfirsich oder nach Wald. Wie riecht das Ganze dann zusammen? Deswegen habe ich mich diese Woche hingesetzt und habe einen Selbstversuch gestartet.
So, wo hast du denn die Duftkästen gekauft?
Also, ich war bei einer Supermarktkette mit neun Buchstaben und habe dann zwei verschiedene Gerüche gekauft und ich habe gekauft Kirche. Ich kann dir nicht zuhören. Ich kann dir nicht zuhören. Rossmann. R-O-S-S-M-A-N-N. Nein. Ich habe gekauft Vanille. Was ist so? Du musst auch mal von anderen. Ich habe zwei Duftkerzen gekauft. Ich habe gekauft Vanille. Aber du wolltest auch nicht mehr kaufen. Also Wissenschaft ja, aber nicht zu jedem Preis. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich habe zwei Kerzen gekauft. Ich habe gekauft Vanille und was es gab war Käsekuchen. Käsekuchen. Ja, ja. Da dachte ich mir, wow, das ist was, was ich mir in einem Film vorstellen könnte. Ja, zum Beispiel Twin Peaks. Oder Ratatouille. Ja, Twin Peaks, da isst er ja Kirschkuchen. Stimmt. Da kann man sagen, oh, den Kuchenaroma von Käsekuchen zu dem Kirscharoma dazu oder irgendwie sowas, Kirschkuchen. Wenn wir das machen sollten, gemeinsam als Geschäftspatter, musst du das Aroma sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es richtig ist, aber das so ... Was sag ich, der Aroma? Der Aroma. Ich sag der Aroma? Ja. Und das möchte ich nicht mehr erleben müssen. Okay, vielen Dank für das Feedback, Herr Tietze, dass Sie das so direkt ansprechen, das schätze ich sehr hoch an meinen Mitarbeitern und dann werde ich das ab jetzt anders machen. Danke für den Input. Und also, Experiment startete um 21 Uhr. Spät? Ja, ich dachte mir, das ist so die Zeit, wo man vielleicht nochmal einen Film anschmeißt. Nö, ich glaube, du hast es vor dich hingeschoben. Ich glaube, du hast die Aufgabe, du warst so faul und hast gar keinen Bock noch irgendwie dienstags noch darüber Gedanken zu verschwenden, was wir beim Podcast für den Kott gelaufen haben. Das ist nicht ganz falsch. Ich wollte es eigentlich schon ein bisschen früher machen, aber ich dachte mir, abends ist so die perfekte Stimmung, da hat man irgendwie, vielleicht der Tag ist so fast vorbei,
man schmeißt nochmal einen Film ran
und genießt dann eine Kerze
dazu. Also, ich hatte
Käsekuchen und Vanille und
ich dachte mir, was mache ich zuerst an?
Dann habe ich mir überlegt, wie könnte der Film
anfangen vielleicht? Und dann dachte ich, okay, der fängt
vielleicht an mit
irgendeinem Polizeidrama.
Ja, man ist in so einem Diner und man setzt sich zusammen und es gibt am Anfang so einen super intensiven Dialog, siehe Pulp Fiction, siehe Inglourious Basterds, super intensiver Dialog, wo man irgendwie merkt, okay, krass, die sind beide undercover, irgendwie so zwei Gangster und man merkt, die sind beide undercover und versuchen sich beide gerade irgendwie zu überführen und es ist so nur durch Blicke und so und nur durch so
wie die Gabel so auf dem Teller
kratzt, so nervös und so.
Und dann dachte ich, die könnten
ja Käsekuchen essen.
Und dann geht der Film los mit Two Cheesecakes,
please. Du könntest der Film auch heißen, ist jetzt
egal, aber du könntest der Film auch heißen.
Und dann kriegen die zwei Käsekuchen und dann geht der Film los
und dann mache ich die Käsekuchenkerze
an. Dieser Dialog wird also immer intensiver. Geht auch 20 Minuten. Grossteil des Films ist Käsekuchen-Dialog. Recht lang. Und dann macht man so ein bisschen diesen Kniff, den kennst du ja auch, dass die Szene zu Ende ist. Und die stehen auf und sagen, okay, wir fahren den getrennten Wagen. Das ist auf einmal eine Grammatikdebatte der Film. Und man denkt, oh krass, wem der beiden folgen wir jetzt? Welcher ist unser Protagonist? Das denkst du bei Filmen immer, wenn die rausgehen, wem folgen wir jetzt? Du wirst ja schon wissen, wer der Protagonist ist. Also so, wenn du zwei Figuren hast, die gleich wichtig sind, aber du merkst, dass sie ein Gegner sind. Beide sind sympathischer, beide sind super gut geschrieben, toller packender Dialog, beide sind einfühlsam, man kann sie verstehen, aber sie sind auch so moralisch grau.
Und dann stehen beide auf und sagen so, okay, wir trennen uns jetzt und man denkt so, krass, gehe ich jetzt mit dem einen oder dem anderen. Die Kamera folgt aber weder dem einen noch dem anderen, sondern dem Stück Käsekuchen, das noch auf dem Tisch lag. Und jemand nimmt den Teller und trägt ihn in die Küche und wir folgen dem Käsekuchen. Es war Gift drin! Oh, das ist auch nicht schlecht. Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Da muss ich es nochmal umschreiben. Da muss ich es nochmalewrite machen. Aber wir sehen dann so einen Zeitsprung und solche Sachen usw. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt haben wir so gute zehn Minuten im Film. Aber du hast noch gar nichts dazu gesagt, wie das gerochen hat. Genau, ich dachte, jetzt sind wir so gute zehn Minuten im Film, der Käsekuchengeruch sollte sich jetzt eingestellt haben. Also ich schaue auf die Uhr nach zehn Minuten, ich schnuppere mal und ich habe nichts gerochen. Was? Ich habe gar nichts gerochen. Wo hast du dich hingestellt denn? Du wirst dich in ein anderes Zimmer stellen. Ich habe mich auf mein Sofa gesetzt und da ist so ein, wie sagt man, so ein Tisch vorm Sofa. Couchtisch. Ja, so ein Sofa, Couchtisch. Beistell, Couchtisch. Ja, so ein tiefer Tisch. So ein Lounchtisch. Tee, Tee, tiefer Tisch. Lounchtisch? Lounchtisch. Stand da, da stand die Kerze drauf. So, ich saß auf dem Couch. Jetzt muss eine Sache dazu. Diese Couch, die sammelt immer viel Staub an, weil ich benutze die eigentlich nur, wenn ich mal so Filmabend mache. Das mache ich vielleicht so einmal in der Woche, alle zwei Wochen oder so mache ich Filmabend. Und dann habe ich so eine große Decke, eine schwarze Decke und die ziehe ich um mich drüber und dann sitze ich auf der Couch. Und da hat sich dann immer viel Staub angesammelt. Und ich bin Stauballergiker. Was leider dazu führt, dass ich meistens intensiv niese. Und zum Filmabend gehört für mich immer eine dicke Packung Taschentücher dazu. Und auch eine verstopfte Nase. Und jetzt kam das leider zusammen, was nicht hätte zusammenkommen können sollen, denn dadurch, dass ich so viel niesen musste, war meine Nase so verstopft und mein ganzes Riechorgan so irritiert, dass ich nichts von dem Käsekuchen gerochen habe, gar nichts, überhaupt nichts. Ich dachte mir, okay, jetzt kommt vielleicht die nächste Szene, dass die irgendwie diesen so Mafia-Leute oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ich weiß nicht, warum wir diesen Film nicht mehr kennen. Die sind hinter der, also es gibt ja immer so eine Front,
also so ein legitimer Laden,
hinter dem dann immer so die Mafia-Operation steht.
Irgendwie bei Sopranos ist diese Metzgerei,
wo die immer in den Hinterräumen dann so sind.
Und da ist es, dachte ich mir, vielleicht ein Kerzenladen.
Ja, convenient, convenient für unseren Film, also für unsere ersten Movie-Send-Kerze, die wir rausbringen wollen, ist es sehr convenient, dass plötzlich ein Kerzenladen ist. Warum nicht? Kerzen sind perfekt zur Gelbwäsche, weil die halten sich ewig. Du musst nicht irgendwie roes Fleisch oder so. Jetzt sagt das doch nicht so laut, dass sich Kerzen so gut zur Geldwäsche eignen. Und ja, und dann fahren wir eben in diesen Kerzenladen und wir denken, ah krass, der ist gar kein Gangster, der arbeitet im Kerzenladen. Und er sagt dann so, ja hier, das sind die Kerzen, hier gibt es verschiedene Gerüche, Blaubeubeere. Dafür, dass wir erst so einen Quentin Tarantino-artigen Dialog hatten, das ist jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen wo hier das Stilbruch. Na ja, pass mal auf. Das sind die Kerzen. Blaubeeren. Blaubeeren. Und wir merken und dann geht die und dann sagt der Kunde sagt, kann ich die denn auch mal ausprobieren, kann ich die denn mal riechen? Ja. Und dann sagt ja gerne, ich mache ihn eine an und er machte die Vanillekerze an. Ah, okay. Gott sei Dank, wir haben Blaubeer nicht. In dem Moment lösche ich also, weil das war der Hintergrund des Experiments, inwiefern kann man mehr riechen. Ich lösche die Käsekuchenkerze aus, puste ich auch aus. Wo ich dachte, Pusten ist vielleicht schlecht, dann habe ich Rauch, aber ist egal. Puste ich aus, zünde Vanillekerze an also jetzt und dann. Wie schnell hat das geklappt? Das ging super schnell. Das eine Bewegung. Super schnell. Ich hatte das Feuerzeug in der rechten Hand und ich habe das Feuerzeug mit der rechten Hand angemacht und habe es neben mein Gesicht gehalten, aber rechts neben mein Gesicht, so dass selbst wenn ich puste, die Feuerzeugflamme nicht Gefahr läuft zu erlöschen. Und mach also die Kerze aus, im nächsten Moment sofort die Flamme am Docht der Vanillekerze, Kerze zwei. Kerze brennt. Hast du jetzt eine Glaskuppel, so eine Käseglocke, genommen und auf die alte Kerze draufgestülpt.
Wobei, bei dir ist scheissegal, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt deine dicke Nase, du riechst gar nichts mehr.
Das Ding ist nämlich, und ich hätte gleich noch ganz viele Fragen, die wir klären müssen,
weil ich finde diese Idee nach wie vor toll und wir sollten das umsetzen.
Duftkerzen werden normalerweise entweder mit einem Deckel geliefert oder mit so einer Glocke. Ich habe auch schon mal Duftkerzen mit so einer Glasglocke gesehen. Sehr teuer. Ja, aber das heißt ja auch, die sind so intensiv und die würden noch die ganze Zeit richtig gute Duftkerzen, riechen ja schon den ganzen Raum voll, wenn die nicht an sind. Die stehen da rum und die riechen alles voll. Ich habe so eine Duftkerze
gehabt, so eine Soja-Duftkerze. Die riecht nach Soja? Ne, ne, ne, die ist aus Soja. Das ist so der
Fettträger da drin, aber der Duft heißt Los Angeles und der ist wirklich geil. Und ein Kumpel
von mir dann auch und wir haben beide beschlossen, dass das so riecht ein Sommerhaus am Meer.
Das war das perfekte, perfekte Ruch, und die kannst du auch nicht stehen lassen, einfach auf dem Tisch. Die hat aber so einen Drehdeckel, die kannst du da draufstülpen. Gut, das ist vielleicht der zweite Schritt, das habe ich nicht gemacht. Genau. Das heißt, die erste Käsekuchen war weiterhin offen, auch in der Nähe der anderen Flamme. So, und dann dieser, im Film sehen wir jetzt bei, die Vanillekerze geht an und der Protagonist sagt so, ja, das ist sehr beruhigend und also diese Vanilledüfte, das ist immer gern genommen, das nehmen viele Leute, auch als Geschenk ist das immer gern genommen, weil auch das bleibt recht lang im Raum, also selbst wenn die Kerze aus ist, denken viele, ach nein, jetzt ist der schöne Geruch aus. Aber nein, das bleibt, also auch hier, der Dialog muss leider darin gestrickt werden. Und dann lasse ich das Ganze so zehn Minuten weiterlaufen, ich habe mir die Uhr gestellt, nach zehn Minuten kam das Ergebnis des Tests, ich habe mir überlegt, okay, wir hatten jetzt zehn Minuten Käsekuchen, zehn Minuten Vanille, was rieche ich?
Rieche ich Vanille, rieche ich Käsekuchen, rieche ich eine Mischung. Ich schnuppere also in den Raum und ich rieche gar nichts. Weil immer noch von dem Staub, der ganzen Stauballergie, sozusagen ich so oft niesen musste, dass ich nichts gerochen habe. Und auf den Film nicht gehört hast. Meine Ohren waren so angeschwollen. Ich beschließe also in diesem Moment
das Experiment zu beenden,
puste also,
ich habe versucht von der Couch aus, sitzend,
klar, das Haus zu pusten hat nicht funktioniert.
Nee.
Und da bin ich ein bisschen näher gerückt.
Puste es aus, Experiment beendet, gescheitert.
Also so viel zum Thema Schichtenduft. Okay, dann machen wir es jetzt zur Chefsache. Ich würde das nämlich dann selber eingehen. Nee, musst du nicht. Als Chairman von Worst Bird Productions würde ich das jetzt gerne dann selber noch mal in die Hand nehmen. Soll ich dir die Kerzen bringen? Auf gar keinen Fall. Okay. Ich weiß nicht, was ich mit denen machen soll jetzt. Ja, mach die doch einfach mal an. Mach die doch einfach mal an. Okay. Ich glaube, es tut nicht deiner Wohnung jetzt einen Abbruch. Okay, das war ein bisschen gemeint, aber gut. So, ich würde nämlich pro forma erst mal sagen, dass ich per se bessere Kerzen kaufen würde.
Der Supermarkt mit den acht Buchstaben, neun Buchstaben, hat vielleicht nicht die besten Kerzen im Angebot, behaupte ich mal jetzt. Ich würde das mal versuchen mit coolen Duftkerzen, die werde ich auftreiben, werde ich auch auf unserer Firmenkreditkarte kaufen. Das vergisst du nämlich immer offensichtlich, weil ich sehe die Abbuchungen und du hast jetzt nicht die Kredite. Aber auch nett, danke, dass du das privat gemacht hast. Naja, da muss man ja auch erstmal privat investieren. Damit du so in einem Projekt wirklich leidenschaftlich dabei bist, musst du ja eigenes Geld investieren. Weil ich bin da so im Duftgame wieder drin. Ich habe richtig, richtig, richtig Bock darauf, das mal auszuprobieren und würde das mal gerne ausprobieren. Ich habe viele Fragen. Also, die muss man sich ja vorstellen, dass die wahrscheinlich nicht so breit ist, sondern relativ schmal. Hoch, ja. Relativ hoch und relativ, ja, eher kerzenähnlich als duftkerzenähnlich, ne? Ja, kerzenähnlich, glaube ich, ist eine gute Stossrichtung, an der wir uns orientieren. Nee, verstehst du, eher classic Kirchenkerzen-mäßig hoch. Nicht dick und dosenförmig breit. Eine hohe, dünne Kerze. Ja, genau so, kann man das auch formulieren. So, und das heißt, jetzt die Frage schon, wie ist sie verpackt, müsste sie ja fast, weil wenn es wirklich eine hohe, dünne Kerze ist, dann riecht ja nämlich siehe Käseglocke, riecht es ja die ganze Zeit schon nach allen Gerüchen. Ja, aber da bin ich jetzt erstmal skeptisch. Du sagst, man müsste Duftkerzen gar nicht anzünden, das ist nur ein Gimmick mit dem Anzünden, eigentlich duften die auch schon ohne Flamme? Die duften auch schon ohne Flamme, mit natürlich, machen wir uns nichts vor. Da würde ich ja jetzt nicht was erfinden oder so. Ist natürlich besser.
In welcher Art besser? Intensiver. Vielleicht riecht es sogar ein bisschen anders. Du könntest nicht einfach fünf Duftkerzen in einen Raum stellen, die dann genauso viel riechen wie eine Brände, aber halt unendlich lange. Aber ich meine, die duften sich ja auch irgendwann leer oder nicht. Das ist ja auch so ein Ding. Irgendwann hören die auch auf. Ich habe mich auch gefragt, warum wir diese Duftkerzen, die nicht droppen und sagen, das ist einfach so ein Diffuser mit so 18 Patronen drin.
Ja, gibt es alles, gibt es alles, habe ich recherchiert, gibt es. Für Filme? Es gibt tatsächlich so eine Art Grundgeruchklaviatur, aus denen man alle Gerüche herstellen kann. Du brauchst so 20 Basisgerüche und die kannst du, wenn du sie unterschiedlich mischst, mehr oder weniger jeden Geruch herstellen. So und dann kannst du sagen, ich will, dass es jetzt riecht nach Stoff. Aber jetzt wird es zu einem grossen Gerät. Das ist ein grosses Gerät, das ist eine Orgel, das ist eine riesige Orgel. Also wir reden jetzt von orgelgrossem Gerät. Die ganzen Flöten sind gefüllt, grösst als der Fernseher. Ja, das ist ein grosses Ding. Aber das ist mir nicht so unromantisch. Immer daran denken, wer ist unsere Zielgruppe? Dumme Menschen, die anderen dummen Menschen dumme Geschenke schenken. Sag das jetzt nicht so. Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist der größte Zielmarkt, den es gibt. Leute haben keine Ahnung, was sie schenken sollen, deswegen kaufen sie irgendwelche dummen Scheisskerzen, wo man beim Geschenk übergeben kann, ach krass, was ist das, ja, du magst doch so gern Babydriver, hier, das riecht nach abgefahrenen Reifen, 30 Minuten lang, ciao. Perfekt, perfektes Geschenk, so, und das ist die Idee, deswegen glaube ich, brauchst du so einzelne Kerzen, die du für 12,99 verkaufen kannst, Geschenk machen kannst und nicht irgendwie so eine riesige Grufsorgel, wo man einfach eine halbe Wohnung für diese Einbauorgel verbraucht. Die Einbauorgel finde ich auch zu viel, also wo du auch Löcher in die Wand bohren musst und das erstmal reinsetzen musst und groß aufwendig installieren und so. Und das Ganze ist dann so im unteren Preissegment bei 3.900 Euro ansässig und die besseren Modelle dann schon mal wie so ein Kleinwagen, nein. Aber ich finde, bei der Kerze sollte auch so eine Halterung und eine Schraube beiliegen, dass man die an die Wand bohren kann. Dass man die auch einfach an die Wand bohren kann. Was dann jemand macht, niemand will, aber einfach als, es ist ein Angebot. Aber falls mal jemand das will, der würde sich dann ärgern, dass es da nicht dabei ist. Ja. Und Batterien sind auch. Oder sie ist sogar unten. Batterien sind im Lieferumfang enthalten. Wir schreiben, Batterien sind im Lieferumfang enthalten. Und alle, hä? Also aber niemand ärgert sich, weil. Nee, kann man immer nicht gebrauchen. Irgendwie unsere Zahnbürste ist auch dabei. Einfach so als, warum nicht, braucht man immer. Reise-Zahnbürste. Und die Kerze ist unten auch so eine Halbkugel, dass man sie nicht auf den Tisch stellen kann. Man muss sie an die Wand bohren, damit man die benutzen kann. Ich habe noch nie eine Duftkerze gesehen, die kerzenförmig, also die lang und schmal ist. Weißt du? Noch nie gesehen. Aber ja, die kann ja auch dann so aussehen wie jetzt bei Star Wars, wie so ein Lichtschwert. Mein Gott, ihr Nerds fahrt doch da ab auf sowas. Oder bei Indiana Jones ist die Kerze eine Peitsche. Meine Güte, es muss halt was langes, dünnes sein, wo du, glaube ich, in jedem Filmuniversum was dazu findest. Hier bei Kill Bill ist es dann so ein Katana-Schwert, dann bei Spaceballs zum Beispiel ist es auch ein Lichtschwert. Lichtschwert. Bei Star Wars Episode 2 ist es jetzt, sagen wir mal, auch ein Lichtschwert. Ja, genau. Da könnte ich jetzt wirklich unendlich lange so weitermachen. Ich glaube, wir finden bei jedem Film irgendwas. Ich glaube, du könntest neunmal so weitermachen. Ich weiß nicht. Also, ich bin mittlerweile skeptischer als noch zu Beginn. Okay. Aber dann war es ein gelungenes Experiment, weil es kann ja auch sein... Dein Experiment war komplett Schwachsinn. Wieso meinst du damit? Das ist peinlich, für die Wissenschaft peinlich, für den Podcast peinlich. Warum? Experiment ist auch gelungen, wenn es ein negatives Ergebnis hat, wenn man merkt, das funktioniert nicht. Experiment hat immer ein positives Ergebnis, weil man immer was lernt. Ja, dass du ein Vollidiot bist, habe ich jetzt gelernt. Also, dass du dich da mit deiner Allergie auf die Sofa verpflanzt und dann noch 20 Minuten den Film erspinst und mit zu einer Nase versuchst zu riechen und nicht darstellt, dass die Idee gekommen ist, abzubrechen vielleicht. Das war nicht ideal, aber ich wollte es an dem Punkt dann noch einfach durchziehen, weil mir das wichtig ist, das Projekt. Nee, finde ich gut, aber ich würde es gerne nochmal selber probieren und dann können wir nächste Woche nochmal darüber sprechen. Das bleibt erst mal ein paar Folgen so. Also, wenn ihr das jetzt irgendwie im Jahr 2024, dann könnt ihr ja vorskippen die nächsten zehn Folgen und hoffen, dass sie dann irgendwann mal rausgebracht und oder das ganze Projekt Ad acta gelegt wurde. Ja, per se. Genau wie unser Popcorn-Projekt ad acta gelegt wurde. Das wurde pro forma ad acta gelegt. Ja. Boah, ich liebe Latein. Das ist super. Ich hasse Latein auch. Aber es ist eine tolle Sprache. Wollen wir mal wirklich so einen Lateinkurs machen? Nox Latina? Ich habe meinen alten Lateinlehrer, meinen Lateinlehrer, meinen Ex-Lateinlehrer ... Im Grunde ist er immer noch dein Lateinlehrer.
Im Grunde ist er immer noch.
Solange du keinen neuen Lateinlehrer hast, ist er immer noch dein Lateinlehrer.
Ich sagte auch neulich, dass eine Ex-Ex-Freundin ja eigentlich deine aktuelle Freundin sein müsste.
Stimmt, sie war mal deine Ex-Freundin.
Genau, eine Ex-Ex-Freundin.
Ist die Frage, wie man es betont.
Wie auch immer, mein Ex-Lateinlehrer, ich war nämlich in meiner Heimatstadt und habe das Weihnachtsoratorium gehört, und er hat gesungen. Er war mit im Chor und hat das Weihnachtsoratorium gesungen. Was dazu geführt hat, dass ich mich nicht richtig auf die Musik einlassen konnte, sondern mehr meinem ehemaligen Lateinlehrer beim Singen zugeguckt habe. Weil natürlich, wenn du jemanden aus dem Chor kennst, dein Blick gravitates zu diesem Menschen, den du kennst. Ich habe mir letztens, mir ist letztens eine Erkenntnis gekommen, und zwar, ich glaube, der furchteinflößendste Moment meiner Jugend war immer Lateinabfrage, war immer und unser und unser Lehrer hat es auch immer so genossen, so wirklich dann auch so Umschreibungen immer zu machen und heute mal der Blühende und alle so, was hat die Bettina, was ist die Bettinaina der Florentin und er ist so wirklich so sadistisch genossen, einfach so und dann heute kommt der und alle Mädchen oder die einfach so der ganze Raum und ich hatte so eine Angst und letztens bin ich durch den Wald spaziert und dachte mir warum hatte ich eigentlich Angst Es wäre doch völlig egal gewesen, wann ich drangekommen wäre, ich war ja nie vorbereitet. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagt, oh bitte heute nicht, heute nicht, weil du bist ja nie vorbereitet. Und jeder Schüler wird zweimal pro Jahr ausgefragt und wann genau du deine mündliche Sex jetzt kriegst, ist ja egal, weil du bist ja nie vorbereitet. Trotzdem hatte ich jede Stunde brutale Angst, Schweißausbrüche, rückwirkend dachte ich mir, das war alles unnütz. Also das war alles unnötige Angst, weil es eigentlich völlig irrational war. Ja, völlig. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum solche Lehrer, man versteht es ja irgendwie doch, diese Angstklima schüren, also man hat natürlich irgendwie, es sind schon irgendwie so ein paar Machtfantasien. Ja natürlich, aber das würde ich doch auch machen. Ja, weiß ich nicht, ja. Vor allem, wenn die sich alle nicht vorbereiten, wenn die es alle nicht ernst nehmen. Ich denke mir, ich fand es mal eine Zeit lang meines Lebens cool, die Vorstellung Lehrer zu sein, aber jetzt weck ich die Strassenseite, wenn mir Teenager entgegenkommen und denk mir, Oberststufenlehrer zu sein, der ist absolut grauen. Ich weiß noch, dann hat ein Lehrer ... Es ist nach wie vor in meinem Gehirn gebrannt, das war gar nicht so unangenehm, aber unser Englischlehrer hat uns einen R.E.M.-Song vorgespielt. It's the end of the world as we know it. Und wir sollten den analysieren, so den Text, den Songtext, eigentlich eine coole Idee, und dann ein Mädchen so, pff, hören Sie das auch privat? Und er wusste nicht sofort schlagfertig zu sagen, und hat dann so leicht rumgestummelt und immer gesagt, und hat dann die Musik ausgemacht. Oh nein! Und er war eigentlich cool und jung, und er war irgendwie, aber es war irgendwie, weißt du, dann diese Mädchen, die vorne in der ersten Reihe saßen, ähm ... Hören Sie das ... Ari M, ey, da gibt's ja wirklich Uncooleres. Ja gut, aber das war halt so eine Zeit, wo wir alle Avicii gehört haben, und dachten, das ist ... that's art. Und dann vorne lief Ari M und die ... Und dann waren da wirklich so ein paar zickige Girls in der ersten Reihe, die ihn so gefragt haben, Hören Sie das auch privat? Und er war halt dann so ein bisschen überrumpelt, weil er, ja, er hat R.E.M. privat, wollte aber vor den Avicii-Fans vor sich, wollte er das nicht unbedingt zugeben. Und das hat zum sehr unangenehm Moment geführt, wo die auch alle gelacht haben. Und ich weiß nicht mehr, ob ich das im Nachhinein mir zu Recht ersprochen habe, aber ich meine, ich habe gesagt, nee, ich finde R.E.M. auch cool in dem Moment. Was du gesagt hast, weiß ich nicht mehr, ich bilde mir ein Ja.
Du bist aufgestanden, hab gesagt, R.E.M. ist doch cool!
Und die Mädchen drehen sich um und ...
Hahahaha!
Wuh!
Aber was ein unangenehmer Moment, jede Erinnerung an meine Schulzeit endet so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum.
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaub, das hab ich gemacht und ich dachte, ich hab dann einen Spruch kassiert wie Schleimer-mäßig, ne? Beim Lehrer-Einschleim. Ja. Aber es war nicht so, ich wollte mich nicht einschleimen. Ich war gut in Englisch, ich wollte mich nicht einschleimen. Oder sowas. Versuchst du jetzt gerade 20 Jahre später noch, diesen Schleimer-Kommentar zu rechtfertigen und sich dagegen zu verteidigen? Ich frage mich nur gerade, warum ich es gemacht habe. Und ich glaube, es war der einfache Grund, ich fand den Moment so unangenehm und ich war in dem Moment zu sensibel und habe das Herz brechen hören und habe dann gedacht, nee, komm, das muss man jetzt irgendwie auffallen. It was the end of the world as you knew it. It was the end of the world, so I know now. Ja, schwierig. Ich glaube, als du es wusste. Es war das keine Kinder mehr, die sind ja noch keine Kindermusik. Die sind ja cooler angezogen als du, aber das ist ja auch egal. Ich denke mir, an irgendeinem Punkt musst du einfach, da bist du halt wirklich der, der, der, oh, jetzt kommt der dran der Blühende. Ich glaube, das hilft halt, weil er sofort so eine Distanz aufbaut zu den Leuten vor einem. Und die kommen ja gar nicht in die Versuchung zu sagen, hören sie Ari M auch privatM. auch privat? Ja, ja, nee, nee, nee, nee. Och Gott, mir ist gerade eingefallen, dass es auch Räucherstäbchen gibt. Ja. Einfach Stäbchen, die man auf die Tischkante legt, anmacht oder irgendwo hinsteckt, anmacht. Bessere Form, erstens. Okay. Hat sie viel, viel bessere Formen. Zweitens, vielleicht sind sie sogar geruchsintensiver. Aber die gehen halt nicht so lange, ne? Doch. Oder? Doch, doch, doch. Räucherstäbchen so eine Stunde oder zwei? Was ich liebe sind diese My Ten Essentials von GQ, wo man Prominente ihre Ten Essentials vorstellen. Und Seth Rogen hat da Räucherstäbchen mitgebracht und die so angemacht und hingelegt. Oder war es Jonah Hill? Weiß ich nicht mehr. Einer von den beiden. Und das könnte doch unsere Lösung sein. Räucherstäbchen. Aber du kaufst ja nicht ein Räucherstäbchen, da hast du dann gleich eine Packung. Wohin geht man eine Duftkerze? Du kannst ja nicht 20 Räucherstäbchen für Casablanca kaufen. Du schaust den Film ja dann nicht 20 Mal hintereinander an. Ja, zum Sammeln und Tauschen. Das ist ja komplett wahnsinnig. Ich weiß, ja, okay, das ist eine gute Idee. Vielleicht eine bessere Idee als die, die ich hatte, ja. Okay, dann machen wir es so. Da haben wir Räucherstäbchen verkaufen, ein Räucherstäbchen für 10 Euro. Genau. Und da sind dann verschiedene Schichten dran, je nachdem. Das wird teuer genug, sich das überhaupt alle Düfte zu organisieren und so. Ich glaube, in der Herstellung ist das, wir machen damit kein, ich lasse das einfach nur für uns ein Fun-Projekt. Ich glaube, das wäre jetzt reich wert. Du könntest ja auch so Special Effects einbauen, sodass du dann so einen Böller einbaust nach 20 Minuten, so da, wo dann irgendwie die große Verfolgungsjagd ist und er gegen die Mülltonne fährt und dann machst du einfach so in dem Moment, in dem er gegen die Mülltonne fährt, so ein Pff, Pff, Pff, sowas halt einfach mit rein oder so, so ein Rauch. So Funken kurz. Einfach raus. Es gibt ja so Rauchgranaten oder so, die dann so Rauch erzeugen. Cool. So was, oder so Magnesium, die dann so Britzel, Bratzel erzeugen oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und das kann man ja auch mit einbauen. Also Feuerwerkskörper. Ja, genau. Kleine Miniraketen. Es wird immer mehr zu so einem kleinen Tischfeuerwerk, was man so nebenher stellt. Ja, das stimmt. Was auch sehr unförmig ist und an sehr vielen Enden hast du so Zünschen, die mal so rausgehen an so gewissen Ecken des Kartons und ab und zu werden die mal abgefeuert. Ja, das ist eine Spaskaskade. Das ist eigentlich so der moderne
Domino Day, dass du so eine lange Kettenreaktion hast
nur mit Lunden. Die Hard
ist quasi nicht
von einem Mann zu tragen. Die Apparatur,
die man kaufen muss für Die Hard,
ist so eine Riesenkarton.
So eine Schubkarre angeliefert.
Da kommt dann extra einer von unseren Lieferanten vorbei.
Wohingegen Dune, übersichtlich.
Ja, sandig.
Sandgeruch. Da liegt dann auch so ein Schleifpapier bei. Ja. Und dann so reiben sie sich leicht über den Arm, während sie den Film anschauen. Reiben sie ihren Partner, ihre Partnerin leicht über den Arm. Um die raue Oberfläche von Atreid, nee. Atreid ist das Haus. Nee, nee. Ascat, Ascat. Wie heißt noch mal die ... Stimmt, Ascat war's.
Der Planet Ascat.
Nee, ähm ...
Spice ist das Gewinne.
Atrakis, Atrakis?
Ah ja, das ...
Nee, Atreides, nee, Atreides ...
Atme schon, da fügen wir an. Wir sind Full Circle.
Nee, Atrakis.
Atrakis, Atrakis? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ist auch nicht. Ist auch nicht so spannend. Scheiße, warum alles mit A anfängt. Ich habe mir so viel Mühe gegeben, bei dem Film alle zu merken, so die Harkonnen, die Fremen. Ich habe wirklich immer wie in so einem Vokabelkasten immer wieder alles durchgegangen und dachte mir, noch komme ich mit, noch komme ich mit, noch komme ich mit. Anders als Matrix der neue, aber das hast du nicht gesehen.
Wir wollten eigentlich hier schön Antenne Aesop machen, aber hat nicht funktioniert.
Antenne Aesop können wir nächste Woche machen.
Diese Woche hätte ich Antenne Annette machen können.
Gott sei Dank, fängt er auch mit an.
Ein Film, den ich geguckt habe.
Shoutout an Leos Karaks, ich weiß nicht, wie er ausspricht, der den geschrieben hat.
Shoutout an Leos Karaks. Okay, ist hiermit gegrüsst, würde ich sagen. Liebe Grüße, altes Haus. Ich weiß nicht, ich kenne den Namen nur geschrieben. Ich glaube, ist ein richtig geiler, so ein alterwürdiger französischer Director, ein bisschen provokativ die ganze Zeit unterwegs, viele Skandalfilme gemacht und er ist die Silberne Palme in Cannes gewonnen für seinen Film Annette. Ein Musicalfilm mit dem lieben Adam Driver. Auch hier nochmal Shoutout an Adam Driver. Ja, Shoutout an Adam Driver und Marion Cotillard. Steht mal auf gerade, ihr beiden. Der Applaus für euch, ihr beiden. Fun, also ich weiß nicht, nee, weiß ich nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Wir machen das alles nächste Woche und reden über Matrix, dann habt ihr noch eine Woche Zeit, euch den anzuschauen und dann reden wir drüber. Also diese Woche Hausaufgabe, an euch da draußen, an Nett gucken und Matrix gucken, nächste Woche machen wir nämlich genau eine Hälfte der Folge einen grossen Cut und reden dann über den jeweils anderen Film. Oder wir vergessen es komplett, schauen beide Filme nicht und reden über den normalen Kram.
Bis dahin macht's gut, habt eine schöne Woche, wir sehen uns das nächste Mal wieder und wir heben ab!